[Music]
back in 1993 a first-person shooter took
the world by storm simply titled doom
fast-forward 27 years and it's about to
happen all over again
doom eternal is finally here throwing
together tens of thousands of hells
demons and the only person capable of
eliminating every last one of them here
are 24 things you need to know about
doom eternal
[Music]
[Music]
for those who have lost track of
whereabouts doom eternal fits in the
whole saga here's a quick catch up this
new entry is a direct sequel to the 2016
doom which itself was a reboot of the
series so I guess in essence this is
doomed to - you know what let's not jump
down that rabbit hole all you need to
know is that one of gaming's goriest
shooters is back and bigger than ever so
fans of the previous installments have
plenty to be excited about here is our
hero that dooms slayer his mum and dad
definitely gave him a good name and oh
boy he lives up to that name she was
once a marine building his reputation
throughout many missions in fact he was
so good at killing demons that his
enemies decided to entomb him in a
sarcophagus and warned the entirety of
Hell to never let him out spoiler alert
he got out
[Music]
several months have passed since then
and now we arrive at the promise of doom
eternal just like it did in the original
doom to the forces of hell have invaded
earth and things are getting pretty ugly
around 60% of the planet has been
conquered by the invading forces our
military is outgunned and the majority
of the world's population is already
dead
happy days just when it looks like
things couldn't get any worse in walks
dooms lair fresh out of hell literally
armed to the teeth we take control of
this lair as he quest to destroy the hel
priests and send those demons back to
where they came from now let's talk
about the most successful element of the
new and improved doom formula the
gameplay at the core of this design is a
simple philosophy push forward gameplay
is the idea that standing in the same
place or biding your time should never
be an option let me break that down a
little with this example in Doom health
does not regenerate like it does in most
other games you play instead you have to
pick it up as well as find it of course
making it an incredibly valuable
resource well you may find some health
stashed around here or there there's
only one guaranteed way to get that
health back the glory kill these are
up-close brutal executions you can
trigger on enemies once their health is
low enough getting close trigger the
glory kill and watch the precious health
come pouring out on the surface this
sounds counterintuitive right the only
way to get health is to leave your cover
and leave that safety behind and run
straight at the enemy the crazy thing is
that it genuinely works and gives the
game an insane pace every encounter is a
pure adrenaline rush thanks to the push
forward gameplay and doom eternal is
doubling down on this in every way
imaginable
this isn't the end of the boss to the
wall game mechanics glory kills equal
health regen but what about if you need
ammo well your doom Slayer has a
chainsaw as you do I'm eliminating a
demon with a chainsaw will gift us with
ammunition if you haven't guessed
already this isn't a simulation demon
slaying game so embrace the arcade
elements as much as you can to finish
this trilogy of murder we can also
regenerate armor and would you like to
guess how we do that with fire kill it
with fire you'll have armor for days
these mechanics turn ordinary combat
encounters into something that feels
more like a strategy game planning three
moves ahead to be fully healed with max
armor and deep pockets of ammunition
moments before a boss fight you are
constantly evolving what you need to
survive and all paths lead to murder
make no mistake about it doom eternal
looks like a game about mindless murder
but the amount of tactical thought going
on beneath the surface is the core of
the brilliance of this game on top of
this doom eternal gives you more tricks
to exploit a great example of this our
enemies new weak spots
rather than demons being big bloody
bullet sponges you can now target
specific areas for an advantage take the
arachnid rod for example this spider
like monster jumps around the
environment taking shots at you from its
plasma cannon solution destroy the
plasma cannon of course if you
successfully blow off part of a monster
you'll hear this satisfying ting noise
who doesn't get a little satisfaction
from some onomatopoeia
that sounds signals you have the upper
hand in this fight my favorite example
of this involves the infamous caki demon
these big one-eyed floating testicles
occasionally have a ridiculous amount of
health but if you manage to fire a
grenade
directly into its open mouth you'll
instantly be able to activate a glory
kill
simply beautiful doom eternal is
confirmed to have twice as many demons
to fight as in previous entries while
you can expect plenty of reimagined
demons based on the original series I'm
personally excited to take on the doom
hunter a brand new enemy type designed
specifically to do one thing does his
name give it away
doom hunter yeah he's here to hunt us
down but nothing can match our dominance
right I guess we'll have to wait and see
fortunately the roster of enemies isn't
the only thing increasing in size the
Slayers own arsenal of super weapons is
seeing its own improvements and some of
them are downright crazy take the super
shotgun for example it's one of the most
iconic weapons in videogame history so
what does doom eternal do to it it adds
a grappling hook meat hook attachment
thing essentially a glorified grappling
hook that allows the Slayer to fling
himself around the environment and yes
face-first into enemies themselves oh
and of course there's the fan-favorite
crucible the doom Slayers very own
energy sword you won't just be handling
the stock variants of these weapons
either much like the previous entry doom
eternal features an overwhelming amount
of upgrade options to suit almost every
play style your core health armor and
ammo levels can be upgraded using
Sentinel crystals with various perks
unlocked along the way on top of that
each weapon can be upgraded to either
increase its effectiveness or to be
modded to give extra use there's a
surprising amount of flexibility here
take the heavy canon machine gun for
example you could choose to add a
precision bolt a sniper like
semi-automatic shot that packs a huge
punch or you could slap on a twin rack
of micro missiles that aggressively seek
out their targets different strokes for
different folks
[Music]
in fact let's go deeper down this rabbit
hole of modification the majority of
weapons we encounter can house two mods
to use as we see fit but here's the best
thing to think about
on our journey will be given a codex of
demons that we've slayed reading this
codex you will highlight different
weaknesses for certain enemy types and
then simply modify your weapons to best
suit that encounter basically what I'm
saying is adapt your arsenal to fit the
fight you're in but as we already know
it's not enough just killing a demon you
have to look good
whilst doing it while the Slayer is a
famous pray to suit also has its own
suite of passive upgrades that we stack
upon as we progress it's also been
modified with a few new tools since its
last outing a new shoulder mounted
equipment launcher can fire frag
grenades or act as a straight-up
flamethrower giving you a ton of new
options in combat then there's the doom
blade a badass knife that's now mounted
to the suits left arm what I love about
the doom blade is that it seems to serve
no purpose whatsoever other than letting
you slice and dice through demons
whenever you get up close and personal I
suppose he could use it to open canned
goods maybe I'm overthinking this to
break away from combat for a moment
doom eternal has a few nonviolent things
to showcase the clearest example of this
is the game's new traversal system while
the doom Slayer has always been a
surprisingly nimble guy this time around
he can double jump and even double dash
his way around a surprisingly diverse
environment pretty soon you'll be
avoiding waves of fire swinging from
pole to pole and climbing up walls in
your pursuit of collectibles not bad for
a guy wearing a suit that probably
weighs more than your mum let's talk
about difficulty doom eternal is making
sure all players get the right level of
challenge in the last game whenever you
up the difficulty enemies began to
behave differently frustratingly they
would become so much more accurate it's
software have recognized this and made
changes making higher difficulties more
fun to play in Doom eternal or mechanics
are scaling which means players at all
levels still have to engage in all the
systems necessary to survive they won't
suddenly find enemies miraculously
activating aimbot just because they
decided to play on a harder
for the true sadist out there have no
fear this doesn't mean the game is going
to be easy on you in fact doom eternal
has added new optional objectives for
those who love getting the crap kicked
out of them slayer gates these are the
new optional encounters you'll find
during your playthrough unlock the gate
with a nearby slay key and you'll find
yourself engaging in some of the hardest
encounters the game has to offer
after all that killing even the doom
Slayer needs to put his feet up from
time to time and that's where we see the
fortress of doom the Slayers new home
away from home
this brand new hub area is one of the
coolest additions to this year's game
the fortress is actually a Space Station
of sauce floating through space keeping
an eye on Hell on Earth here you can
access previously completed missions
test your might in the training area
called the demon prison or watch over
the construction of what happens in the
later game well we haven't seen the full
extent of what the fortress will become
we have had a peek at some of the glory
secrets and easter eggs including doom
Slayers personal collection of guitars
and an old-school PC that lets you play
the original doom assuming that you find
all the floppy disks insert a joke here
about my three-and-a-half inch floppy I
do hope you get that joke if all of this
sounds like a lot of content to stuff
into the game you're damn right it is so
the days of six to eight hour campaigns
are over doom eternal will last 22 plus
hours this is going to last you some
time indeed one of the more interesting
ideas which will be implemented after
the game releases are invasions a
hardcore activity for n game players
they will be given the opportunity to
disrupt and enter another player's game
obviously you have to turn this feature
on to be part of it so you're not
suddenly going to be crushed by someone
who hasn't left their house in seven
days but this could be really cool we'll
wait and see but I like the idea on top
of this doom eternal comes bundled with
a new multiplayer mode inspirationally
titled battle mode this is a two versus
one affair in which the doom Slayer
takes on two demons over five rounds the
two minions of hell need to kill the
doom Slayer norming feat whereas the
doom Slayer will need to kill both the
demons but
the kicker after he kills the first one
you'll have 20 seconds to hunt down and
murder the second
this will bring a cat-and-mouse element
to the game-mode making things feel more
frantic if you're wondering what happens
should he fail while the dead demon
responds with 50% of their health and
the round continues from there whoever
wins around can summon something
mind-blowing the demons can call upon
the baron of hell and if the Slayer wins
around they can use the BFG 9000 this
mode is a huge part of the game's
replayability going forward so expecting
to be supported for a long time oh here
the new Call Edition will see a classic
weapon option for doom purists with this
mode turned on our weapon will be placed
in the exact center of the screen just
like in the 1990s it's not a big thing
it's just a weird thing which pays
homage to the early games and we can't
talk about a doom game without
mentioning the soundtrack the 2016
soundtrack blew our minds and we can
confirm the producer behind those Tunes
is back all hey old Mick garden whatta
guy okay before we go let's go through a
few housekeeping options there will be a
dlc season pass which will add content
to the single-player portion of the game
the multiplayer modes on the other hand
will be regularly updated for free you
don't need the season pass for that one
which is nice there are no
microtransactions in the game again
that's good to know
and finally doom eternal releases on
March 20th on ps4 PC and Xbox and get
this Nintendo switch to but don't expect
60 frames a second there oh and if
you're crazy enough to buy it it's also
out on stadia I'm not judging you you do
you so what do you think are you
grabbing doom eternal I would love to
know your thoughts I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]